so today we're gonna react to some old
really weird BuzzFeed videos so many to
choose from
I'm it's a to see who's in it this is
called Teddy has an operation this is
April 26 2013 I was so in college this
was before I even moved here you would
call how about forgot you're young
Wow this is the beginning of BuzzFeed
there is something wrong with Teddy
don't worry
Teddy the doctors going to find out what
I give him bear oh that's not how you
administer anesthesia because the doctor
is putting you to sleep
this one actually made me so happy when
I first thought when I was just a
resident and I was trying to get hired I
was like oh I didn't know we could do
stuff like this the doctor cuts into
Teddy's flesh with his medical
instrument look there is a bonbon layer
which makes him sweet it's so weird it's
such a weird guy it's like a nice
concept and the voice is soothing but
then what you're watching let's look at
his kidney now the kidney is what gives
Teddy patients those look it's really
realistic like like organ like actually
like organelles
I think that's like a ziplock bag or
something - you won't hate the children
now today never had to get any ROM needs
this is triggering I just had a surgery
oh look
Teddy moved and the doctor replaces it
with curiosity now the doctor must
explore Teddy's heart that is where his
love comes from I love that his heart
healthy days look how much love teddy
has what has gone wrong that's it that
is what happened Teddy loved a bad boy
he is really a child for you to love I
think we've done it it's time to seal
Teddy back up the operation is complete
and soon Teddy will be all better again
I hope you get well soon
that was really sweet it was it was a
very smartly done video the part where
they were using it's like sort of silly
string to like cauterize the wounds was
so clever I like the overall message of
being like sometimes you think that
something's wrong and you have to like
really search for something deeper I
thought that was sweet that was
definitely a fairly high bar for weird
but I think it's gonna get weirder I can
get weirder
[Music]
he had like they had to include for the
first time as though they speaking what
I've done it before I think 3 million
views there was like a mutiny that
happened when the budget were like you
are out of your mind don't do this this
is disgusting I have never watched it oh
my god
that's not unappetizing it's here it's
like Stan why is so yellow well I'm
surprised this video isn't doing one
person it's like there's six people why
would you do this oh yeah you guys oh my
god imagine like this is like your
legacy it's like eating a booger sort of
he's a good eating boogers no one else
let's get away from this stuff that
would go out for casting was pretty wild
and I think what's the weirdest part
about this is I'm pretty sure that
people responded to that email and they
didn't get cast waiting for them to text
you back yeah I have one similar that
was the first one I made no I was like
that's rude no beard Adam oh I already
love this oh this is great great
he is the perfect expression for this he
has a beard now so did they make this
over no you probably had the beard first
of course they went backwards I was like
wow this took so long to make like no
they just shot the lousy first one
animating
[Music]
that's crazy
this isn't photography was like every
shot was really beautiful well opposed
everybody has that like three dots
moment I don't know it's super relatable
it's not that weird thing it's a place
in so many different locations so many
different outfits the whole process of
the beard for a one minute and 20 second
long internet video like that is
dedication it seems like we leaned into
like weird for the sake of being weird
back then it was just like the time we
threw all the spaghetti at the wall to
see what people like and that's a weird
thing is that the Internet change is so
freakin fast yeah well that's a from
four years ago and like that would never
be made now I probably would have had a
harder time getting these greenlit today
but I'm glad they exist and I'm glad
that was like a more experimental time
yeah you know speed history jamming
relics that we can look back on and
reminisce about yes
[Music]